I may look like a nice English lady in a
sensible cards again but these days it's
a thin veneer and it started to crack
who wants to bring kids into this bloody
world my point is I just don't think
that the world needs more case took her
crawl
one of the most unsung figures of
alternative rock hasn't been seen in 20
years that's him wow so gorgeous thank
you I think I've had enough tucker
bloody crows lost 20 lifetimes tucker
has a new album and I don't want to
spend my time with someone who doesn't
get it
well somebody new
Juliette naked is a naked attempt to
squeeze a few more quid out of a
long-dead career you wrote this is the
strangest thing I met someone on the
Internet you're finally entering the
modern age event that review I post it
you nailed it I couldn't have explained
it better myself
Tucker cross Taku Crowe as in Duncan's
Idol taco right yeah it's really me
what's your story theater it's really
odd to be saying all this to a stranger
but I have a hunch I've wasted the last
15 years of my life I don't imagine this
as much of a consolation but I'm ashamed
to say that two decades have slipped
through my fingers at least you have a
pass to live up to big news I am coming
to London would you like to meet for a
drink
we'd nap side while you find you
beautiful spot are you that's me in my
high school chess club so I can explain
this I'm not trying to trap Oh cut your
head off
right Duncan Thompson
Tucker Crowe I'm Stevie Wonder real
mature honey
you are you're drinking sucker Grogg
glass of water I'm not getting a famous
American rock star a glass of wolves I'm
not definite mr. okay and I'm an
alcoholic
well you'll fit right in it's wondering
if you'd be interested in me do you
think there's any way back for me
you sure this doesn't have something to
do with your idol coming along and
fancying me please how do we know that's
even him well I have passport well that
would be simpler well all of this seems
to be in order really oh my god
you